neue pläne für die bundeswehr die
verteidigungsministerin will mit einem
sogenannten jahr für deutschland die
truppe verändern
ein unabhängigkeitstag im wahlkampfmodus
us-präsident jump wettert gegen die
antirassismus bewegung zu corona
schweigt er weitgehend und zu viel regen
in zu kurzer zeit in japan starben bei
überschwemmungen und erdrutschen
mindestens 14 menschen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert könig für den sport ja
guten abend viele fronten schwächen der
zeit die bundeswehr da sind vermehrt
rechtsextremistischer vorfälle es fehlt
an anständige ausrüstung und an personal
ein neuer freiwilligendienst soll helfen
meint verteidigungsministerium annegret
kramp karrenbauer die wehrbeauftragte
des bundestags eva högl wirkt sogar
dafür die wehrpflicht wieder einzuführen
sie gilt im prinzip noch heute wurde
jedoch 2011 für friedenszeiten
ausgesetzt eingezogen wurden männer ab
dem 18 lebensjahr zuletzt für sechs
monate
cornelia schiemenz über die
unterschiedlichen reformideen schon
gleich zu beginn ihrer amtszeit machte
annegret kramp karrenbauer deutlich die
bundeswehr soll wieder tiefer in der
gesellschaft verankert werden was die
verteidigungsministerin darunter
versteht sagt sie heute einen neuen
freiwilligendienst sechs monate
militärische grundausbildung sechs
monate helfende hand innerhalb der
reserve
es geht um die frage was uns in dieser
gesellschaft zusammenhält was der kit
ist und wie wir die stärken die für
diese gesellschaft wirklich etwas tun
wollen die frage ob das verpflichtend
oder freiwillig ist das eine die wir in
unserer zukunftswerkstatt debattiert
haben und die wir auf dem parteitag im
dezember entscheiden wollen in der
korona krise habe sich gezeigt dass jede
hand gebraucht würde
die opposition verwundert über den neuen
vorschlag die zahlen für den
freiwilligen wehrdienst sind ja nicht
unbedingt schlecht also deshalb
erschließt sich mir überhaupt nicht
worum es hier noch mal ein zusätzliches
instrument braucht mir scheint dass er
etwas zu sein was von der cdu kommt und
nicht so sehr der bundeswehr dient die
bundeswehr das dauerstreitthema wegen
gehäufter rechtsextreme vorfälle bringt
sich heute auch die neue wehrbeauftragte
in stellung in zeitungsinterviews sagt
eva högl
ich halte es für einen riesenfehler dass
die wehrpflicht ausgesetzt wurde
wir müssen diese entscheidung sehr
kritisch
ihre unterstützung für hügel von der afd
wehrpflicht ist die sicherste verbindung
zwischen bevölkerung und streitkräften
in der truppe selbst wird die erneute
debatte über eine wehrpflicht begrüßt
die art und weise wie die wehrpflicht
abgeschafft wurde war sicherlich ein
fehler deswegen wäre es unklug jetzt mit
handstreich sozusagen die wehrpflicht
wieder einzuführen aber nichtsdestotrotz
die analyse und debatte darum wäre schon
wichtig die verteidigungsministerin
lehnt eine rückkehr zur wehrpflicht in
alter form ab bezeichnet die neue
debatte dazu als so wörtlich interessant
in den usa ist das corona virus außer
kontrolle die zahl der neuinfektionen
explodiert zudem spalten die
antirassismus proteste das land und was
macht der präsident schüttet zum
unabhängigkeitstag nochmal kräftig öl
ins feuer
und zwar vor ganz großer kulisse in
south dakota jump spricht unter dem
gewaltigen nationaldenkmal von mount
rushmore also unter den in stein
gemeißelten ex-präsidenten washington
jefferson roosevelt und linken
tausende trump fans sind dabei aber auch
die kritiker des präsidenten sind heute
auf den straßen aus den usa peter jäger
am unabhängigkeitstag gibt es für sie
nichts zu feiern sie wollen protestieren
die black lifes meter bewegung ist in
washington wieder auf der straße klare
kante zeigen gegen rassismus
ungleichheit und polizeigewalt die
generation unserer eltern war still und
hat sich angepasst
aber diese generation ist nicht still
wir werden nicht aufhören bis es
veränderung gibt
die usa stecken mitten in einem
kulturkampf und für die auftakt
zeremonie zum feiertag wählte donald
trump ausgerechnet den fuß des mount
rushmore in south dakota die denkmäler
vier große amtsvorgänger im rücken gegen
statuen wie diese richtet sich seit
wochen die wut der protestler trump
teilt gegen sie aus unsere nation wird
zeuge einer mitleidlosen kampagne um
unsere geschichte auszulöschen unsere
helden zu diffamieren unsere werte
auszuradieren und unsere kinder zu
indoktrinieren
jubel beim publikum wie beim zweikampf
veranstaltungen immer wieder sprechchöre
7500 menschen eng gedrängt ganz
überwiegend ohne maske die aktuelle
corona krise hat in trance rede keinen
platz polarisierende botschaften dafür
umso mehr
wütende mob es versuchen die statuen der
gründerväter niederzureißen
sie denken die amerikaner sind schwach
weich und unterwürfig aber die
amerikanischen stark und stolz spricht
von den amerikanern und schließt den
protestierenden teil der bevölkerung wie
hier in washington bewusst aus spalten
statt einen ist seine devise
auch am unabhängigkeitstag ins haus in
washington wie erleben sie diesen
vierten juli in der hauptstadt
da spielt leider der ton nicht mit
insofern grüßen wir nach washington und
bedauern diese panne schauen wir auf die
korona lage in deutschland die zahl der
neuinfektionen geht leicht zurück im
schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 390 menschen neu mit
dem virus angesteckt gestern lag die
zahl bei 430 und auch das sind zahlen am
rande der korona pandemie das robert
koch institut hat seit wochen
gesundheitsdaten gesammelt zdf heute hat
den puls der deutschen ausgewertet
klicken sie sich durch wie sieht es in
ihrem landkreis aus und welchen
zusammenhang gibt es zwischen ruhepuls
und lebenserwartung
bitte schließt nicht wieder als erstes
kitas und schulen wenn irgendwo die
korona zahlen hochschnellen so der
flehentliche appell von eltern heute auf
demos in sieben städten seit vier
monaten herrscht zuhause ausnahmezustand
zwar soll es nach den sommerferien
wieder regulären unterricht geben doch
die angst ist groß dass das nicht lange
gut geht aus frankfurt berichteten
klinge
zum beginn der ferienzeit wollen eltern
noch einmal auf sich aufmerksam machen
die angst ist groß vor einer zweiten
corona welle und vor der
erkältungssaison im herbst und winter
was mache ich wenn manchen schnupfen hat
dann muss es zu hause lassen mein
arbeitgeber macht das nicht mehr mit und
nur wegen ein bisschen schnupfen sind
kinder nicht krank unsere größte sorge
ist dass es nach den ferien woanders
auch so läuft in gütersloh dass die
erwachsenen dazu beitragen mit ihrem
fehlverhalten dass die infektionszahlen
steigen und man reflexartig einfach
wieder schulen und kitas schließt ab
montag startet in hessen wieder der
regelbetrieb in kitas in wiesbaden ist
man zuversichtlich dass der spagat
zwischen infektionsschutz und
kinderbetreuung gelingen kann
ich habe die große hoffnung und auch
setze mich auch dafür ein dass kinder
und deren belange aber auch die belange
von familien nicht nochmals unter die
räder geraten wie das zeitweise während
der ersten welle jetzt geschehen ist
kinderarzt wohl schwerdtfeger hält die
öffnung von kitas und schulen auch wegen
der entwicklung der kinder für wichtig
im zweifelsfall müsse getestet werden
die kinder müssen wieder mehr in die
praxis von den eltern gebracht werden
und je nach risiko lage musste erst
entscheiden kann das kind in den
kindergarten kann es nicht diese eltern
hoffen dass die sommerferien genutzt
werden um sinnvolle konzepte zu
erarbeiten für bildung und betreuung
während der korona zeit die proteste
gegen die fleisch firma tönnies reißen
nicht ab in rheda wiedenbrück in
nordrhein-westfalen kletterten
demonstranten auf das dach des
hauptwerkes der schlachthof müsse
dauerhaft geschlossen werden so die
forderung der aktivisten
denn jetzt steht enorm unter druck
nachdem es hier einen massiven krone aus
burg gegeben hatte in england waren
wegen corona bis heute restaurants
friseure oder pubs geschlossen
jetzt soll ein wenig normalität
zurückkehren und ein stück
jahrhundertealter tradition gerade die
pubs sind für viele engländer der
treffpunkt außerhalb der eigenen vier
wände
mehr als drei monate waren sie dicht
seit dem morgen ist die mischung aus
kneipe und wohnzimmer wieder offen mit
abstandsregeln und hygiene kommt
andreas stamm berichtet einsames bier
sucht abnehmer so viel leere samstags in
englischen pubs sieht man selten laute
musik tv live fußball größere gruppen
nicht erlaubt die folge er gequälte
freude die neuen regeln als spaßbremse
und dazu startschwierigkeiten nach der
zwangspause
meine ersten zwei bier waren war
würde die regierung klare regeln
formulieren und man könnte glauben das
ist sicher wäre die pubs aufzumachen
dann okay aber boris johnson sagt einen
tag das am nächsten tag das gegenteil
ich habe null vertrauen und ewig lockt
das pint pustekuchen die feier laune
verdorben hat vieles die meisten corona
toten in europa weiterhin große probleme
mit dem test und kontakt verfolgungs
system das eine zweite infektionswelle
verhindern soll
oder die schon vorab wieder gestiegenen
infektionszahlen in jedem fünften bezirk
in england schlange stehen deshalb heute
nur bei den friseuren wo es nicht um
vergnügen sondern um notwendigkeit geht
was diesen termin um fünf nach
mitternacht erklärt das ist das erste
mal dass sich das haus verlassen habe
ausgefertigt mit richtigen schuhen
anstatt seit 16 wochen nummer flip flops
kinos restaurants oder vergnügungsparks
dürfen wieder öffnen
symbole der leidenden wirtschaft sollte
ein ruck durch england gehen erstmal
vertagt und auch prinz william konnte
nicht helfen der schon gestern einen
schluck im pub nahm ebenfalls eher
lustlos die lage auf dem rettungsschiffe
viking spitzt sich nach angaben der
besatzung zu es soll mehrere
selbstmordversuche gegeben haben italien
hat ein ärzte team an bord geschickt die
besatzung hatte gestern abend den
notstand ausgerufen
die ocean waking hat etwa 180 menschen
aus dem mittelmeer gerettet
italien und malta sollen dem schiff
untersagt haben einen ihrer helfen
anzusteuern
jetzt zu einem thema das in deutschland
immer mehr zum problem wird es geht ums
grundwasser
experten sagen es sei wie ein bankkonto
unter dem unter von dem unterm strich
mehr abgehoben als eingezahlt
der vergleich macht klar auf dauer kann
das nicht gutgehen
es regnet zu wenig aber jeder möchte
wasser wann immer er will niedersachsen
musste schon gegensteuern wollen ihre
berichtet in diesen tagen kommt unter
fried immer wieder zu beunruhigenden
ergebnissen wenn er an verschiedenen
messstellen in niedersachsen die
grundwasserstände überprüft starke
absenkungen fast überall die letzten
zwei jahre waren extrem trocken die
tendenz setzt sich fort
der klimawandel das mittlerweile auch
niedersachsen angekommen wir haben schon
seit längerem grundwasserstände also
seit beginn der 2000er jahre ungefähr
grund war verständigt die sich auf einem
unterdurchschnittlichen niveau bewegen
wie ernst die lage ist hat fried im
kürzlich veröffentlichten
niedersächsischen grundwasser bericht
beschrieben ein auswertungszeitraum von
31 jahren zeigt wie sehr der
grundwasserstand abgesunken ist es sind
historisch niedrige werte und das in
einem vergleichsweise wasser reichen
land wie niedersachsen die ersten
anzeichen einer wasserkrise sind da sagt
umweltminister olaf lies und plädiert
für eine anderes wassermanagement immer
dann wenn große mengen wasser kommt
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass wir den
raum geben dem wasser raum geben durch
bewaldung durch rückhalte strukturen
durch flächen wo auch wasser gesammelt
und gebündelt werden kann
neue strukturen wassersparende techniken
auch in der landwirtschaft muss anders
beregnet werden bei der methode das
wasser nach oben zu schießen verdunstet
40 prozent der landkreis osnabrück
greift auch deshalb zu drastischen
maßnahmen verbietet bis ende september
die beregnung von grünflächen
landwirtschaftlichen flächen und
sportanlagen von 12 bis 18 uhr
im moment geht es wirklich darum
deutlich zu machen wir müssen wasser
anders wertschätzen
noch ist die wasserversorgung nicht
gefährdet doch vielerorts wird das
grundwasser knapp tausende
motorradfahrer haben in ganz deutschland
gegen drohende fahrverbote an sonn und
feiertagen protestiert die proteste
richten sich gegen eine initiative der
bundesländer
sie wollen den weg für fahrverbote frei
machen und fordern dass motorräder
künftig deutlich leiser sein sollen etwa
vergleichbar mit einem lkw oder einem
rasen her
jetzt haben wir nach japan denn das land
wird von schweren unwetter gebeutelt
mindestens 14 menschen starben
nach heftigen regenfällen gipfel kam es
auf der insel kyushu zu erdrutschen und
überschwemmungen
die stadt toyohashi und weitere orte
sind überflutet und 200.000 menschen
wurden aufgefordert ihre häuser zu
verlassen
thomas konditor joschi eine stadt am
fluss sie ist nun eine stadt im fluss
wasser überall und es steigt es bleibt
nur die flucht auf dächer und höher hier
entkommt eine familie mit kind während
unten naturkräfte wüten ströme reißen
autos brücken teile ja hütten und häuser
mit und verschlucken sie rechtzeitig
raus sie haben das geschafft
um vier uhr nachts wurde es richtig
schlimm
mein haus war bis zum zweiten stock
überflutet hier kam das unheil den berg
herunter
ein erdrutsch schlammmassen machen
häuser zu ruinen helfer suchen nach
überlebenden die regierung schickt
soldaten zur unterstützung
die grüne insel das paradies die natur
hat den menschen hier ihre gewalt
gezeigt und jetzt zu dir nochmal und
fußball heute abend pokal finale der
herren bayer leverkusen gegen bayern
münchen die damen spielen noch also
fangen wir mit der dritten liga hatten
absolut die haben es nämlich jetzt auch
geschafft den letzten spieltag den 38
die würzburger kickers stellen nach
einem 2 2 gegen halle als zweiter
aufsteiger nach eintracht braunschweig
fest die entscheidung fiel in der
nachspielzeit nachdem alles gute den
ball im strafraum an die schulter
bekommen hatte
mannschaftskapitän sebastian schuppan
mit dem elfmetertreffer zum möglichen 2
2 das schließlich fühlt mögliche
würzburger zum sprung in liga zwei
reicht der fc ingolstadt steht in
derselben liga nach dem 2 0 sieg bei
1860 münchen in der relegation gegen den
zweitligisten fc nürnberg und könnte
auch noch aufsteigen das hinspiel in
nürnberg am dienstag ab 18 uhr live im
zdf der hamburger sv und dieter hecking
gehen nach dem verpassten aufstieg in
die erste liga getrennte wege der
vertrag wird nicht verlängert wer
cheftrainer nummer 13 in der hsv
geschichte der vergangenen zehn jahre
wird steht noch nicht fest
frustrierende saison start für formel 1
pilot sebastian vettel der heppenheimer
erreichte im qualifying nicht einmal die
dritte runde und startet morgen im
ersten rennen nur aus der sechsten reihe
die formel 1 saison wird nicht leicht
für den gestern 33 jahre alt gewordenen
in hessen
ferrari hat einen konstruktionsfehler
beim neuen auto eingerannt vettel
beklagt ein unruhiges heck frustrierend
vor allem das esteem konkurrenz erklärt
bis sie die vierte startreihe geschafft
hat die roten abgeschlagen dafür die
schwarzen silberpfeile wieder ganz vorn
im kampf um die pole reicht weiter
roboters trotz des fahrfehlers seine da
vorgesetzte bestzeit aus um vor dem
weltmeister lewis hamilton ins rennen zu
gehen
dahinter lauert max verstappen spielberg
sieger 2008 10 und 19
ich bin der einzige der morgen auf der
etwas härteren reifenmischung fährt
unter den ersten zehn ich freu mich
drauf
das hat im vorjahr schon mal bestens
funktioniert also geht's los
auch formel 1 ohne fans das
sonntagswetter bietet einiges wind und
schauer an der küste und im süden auch
wärme und sonne die details hat gleich
katja horneffer claus kleber begrüßt sie
um viertel nach elf im heute-journal
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen samstagabend und bis
morgen wenn sie wirken auf wiedersehen
[Musik]